so recently I had a client of mine
ringing me up and she was in a really
tricky situation her and her boyfriend
of three years have basically just
broken up now they live in the same flat
together and they've got five months
left on the contract so not only are
they gonna have to share the flat for
another five months because it's a one
bed flat they're gonna have to share the
same bed can you even imagine how
difficult that must be I remember
helping one couple in particular whose
communication had become so toxic that
they could no longer hear and understand
what the other was asking all they heard
were their worst fears let's face it
breaking up is never easy
but when you're in a situation that
forces you to get on with an axe it can
be a really difficult divide to cross
[Music]
people fall madly in love and in my
experience they fall madly out of love
as well you might find yourself in a
tricky situation if you live in the same
halls as your ex at university or you go
to a party or a wedding of a mutual
friend or you happen to work together
often the people I help share children
and assets and although you may not like
them at the moment your ex is likely to
be your best possible resource to help
you look after your children and create
the life that you want for yourself a
messy breakup means that you need to
find creative ways to cross the divide
I know it's not always possible but
really try to give one another proper
space after the break-up
ideally commit to going around six
months to one year of no contact just so
that you give yourself the chance to get
each other out of your systems take
advice from all sources accountants tax
advisers benefit officers whatever is
going to help you the most if you have
an area that you're afraid of if you're
afraid of finances get help don't ignore
it or stick your head in the sand and
hope it will go away it won't embrace it
and grow when you do see your ex in a
social situation go out of your way to
take the high road however difficult
that may be say hello be graceful be
mature so I was in the situation like
this myself a few years ago I had been
asked to do a speech at a festival about
a book that I'd written now this book
was mainly about a really painful
breakup that I'd had with an ex and my
new boyfriend of a year had come to
watch me do this talk and as the
workshop started in walks my ex from the
book with his new girlfriend and look
this could have been such an awkward
situation for my new boyfriend but as
soon as the workshop was over he went
right up to my heir introduced himself
and they ended up really really getting
on so much so that he is very recently
asked my ex to be an usher at our
wedding next year
[Music]
get in touch with the new you and who
you want to be think about where you
might want to be in a year's time be
curious about those options
think about your wider context get back
in touch with your passions your friends
and the person that you may have
compromised in the relationship focus on
the future and the person you want to be
rather than painful events that may have
taken place whatever you do do not put
your mutual friends in an awkward
position by making them choose between
you and your ex or talking really
negatively about your ex behind their
back trust me
this does not put you in a good light
mentalize and empathize with your ex
partners needs and try to be objective
it takes a great deal of emotional
effort to see your ex through that lens
but remember you did love them once and
you did see their positive attributes
they still have them you just can't see
them right now
if you liked this video hit like and
subscribe
you
[Music]